it's the most populous country in the
world with over 1.4 billion people
living here but believe it or not china
has a population problem
here's why
with a population bigger than north
america and europe combined
you wouldn't necessarily think china's
leaders would be worried about how many
people live there
a recent census revealed it has a
population of 1.41 billion people
but the rate of growth is slowing and
more worryingly
the number of babies being born is going
down
in 2020 12 million babies were born over
2 million fewer than the 14.66 million
in 2019.
the population decline hasn't always
been a concern of the chinese government
in fact
previously they welcomed it
[Music]
china has controlled how many children
people can have for decades
the infamous one child policy was first
introduced in 1979
as a way of stopping rapid population
growth outpacing economic development
this was policed with huge fines and
even forced abortions
it led to a huge gender imbalance in
china with many parents choosing to have
an abortion
or even abandon their child if it wasn't
a boy as of 2020
they're around 35 million more males
than females in china
the one child policy was relaxed in 2015
and the government began to allow
families to have two children
but this policy isn't the only reason
the birth rate is so low
[Music]
um
many experts have actually blamed just
how expensive it is to raise a child in
china
housing education and food can cost a
lot in the country
especially in the big cities
so now the government has relaxed the
rules even further and introduced a
three-child policy on its own
probably not the two-child policy did
lead to a short-term increase in the
birth rate
that didn't last very long and reaction
online to the three-child policy
announcement was chilly at best
a poll on sinha's weibo account asked
their followers if they were ready for
the three child policy
and 29 000 people out of the 31 000 who
replied
clicked the never even think of it
option the poll was quickly taken
offline
it is shocking that in 2021 china has
still so much control over women's
bodies
but you could argue that those controls
have been too successful
generations are now used to having small
families in china and as shown in 2015
changing the rules won't necessarily
work
on
the government is trying other things to
stop the aging population
they have promised to increase the
retirement age which will be unpopular
and to expand the pension system which
will be expensive
it isn't the first country to face this
population problem the current fertility
rate is actually in line with italy and
japan
the difference is in other countries
they got rich before they got old
that hasn't happened in china it's why
it's such a big headache for the chinese
government
simply hoping more people have more
babies isn't going to reverse the trend